the universe appears to be 13.8 billion
years old earth-like four-and-a-half
billion years old
million years or so the Sun will expand
and probably evaporate the oceans on
make life impossible on earth which
means that if it had taken consciousness
10% longer to evolve it would never have
balled it all attempts and longer
and I wonder I wonder how many dead one
planet civilizations are out there in
the cosmos that never made it to the
other planet and ultimately extinguish
themselves or were destroyed by external
factors probably a few channeling calls
Sagan look again at that dot that's here
that's home that's us on it everyone you
love everyone you know everyone you've
ever heard of every human being who ever
was lived out their lives the aggregate
of our joy and suffering thousands of
confident religions ideologies and
economic doctrines every hunter and
forager every hero and coward every
creator and destroyer of civilization
every King and peasant every young
couple in love every mother and father
hopeful child inventor and Explorer
every teacher of morals every corrupt
politician every superstar every Supreme
Leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
mote of dust suspended in a sunbeam
our planet is a lonely speck in the
great enveloping cosmic dark in our
obscurity in all this vastness there is
no hint that help will come from
elsewhere to save us from ourselves the
earth is the only world known so far to
harbor life there is nowhere else at
least in the near future to which our
species could migrate this is not true
this is Fault Mars and I think Carl
Sagan would agree with that
he couldn't even imagine it at that time
so thank you for making the world dream
and thank you for talking today I really
appreciate it thank you
you